[Music]
while murderers raised the body count
columbia u still wants the cops out yeah
they want campus police decrees even
after students end up deceased the
student teachers union at columbia
university remains committed to severing
all ties with the nypd while they seem
to be cool with knife-wielding criminals
this is a sentiment also shared by many
undergraduates who continue to push for
the removal of cops from their campus
yeah they want the campus free of cops
the same way their brains are free of
thought
and this despite the fact that two
students in the last two years have been
murdered near school property the most
recent happening earlier this month when
a 30 year old grad student from italy
was randomly stabbed to death in the
stomach while walking home from soccer
practice police arrested the alleged
perp a young gang member with a lengthy
rap sheet we've heard that before during
the george floyd protest columbia
student workers union called for the
university to quote immediately cut ties
with the nypd and the new york city
police foundation and divest from any
funding for police ban police from all
columbia campuses and redirect funds
towards supporting black and indigenous
people
of course black and indigenous people
suffer more when cops aren't around
to their credit the nypd says they
beefed up their presence although using
the word beefed probably triggers the
vegan students
but despite the recent murder these
students would still rather protect
criminals than themselves proving once
more that paying fifty eight thousand
dollars a year in tuition usually means
you're stupid
harry ariel
walter why don't we why don't we give
them what they want
why don't we just say okay
police free just like they did in the
wire you know where they made that one
part of the town
it's like a sanctuary city for criminals
why not do it colombia the purge yes um
well
first of all i went to princeton
university that's a true fact and we
looked down on columbia
i was never sure why we looked down on
columbia but now i feel good about it
um i went to trinity and i looked down
on colombia yeah
the cops hate them too that's the thing
yeah you know the cops aren't there
because they love protecting these
people who dis like them right they're
they're out of duty and this is what
they get i i actually have a young
friend from idaho who's at columbia
university and when i saw this story
about the murders i was afraid for him
right and and there are people from all
over the world expecting colombia to
protect them they're not all american
liberals there they're they're people
from you know little towns and other
countries and so on and to and to
expose them to this american woke
madness is is is so uh
inhospitable i mean it's just it's wrong
that is true because when peop people
come here because they feel safe and
because of just the values that america
has and then you go to a campus where
they actually hate the values paris they
get there and they go like did they
escape guatemala right for the for and
now i got to deal with like the or the
lawlessness of brazil or something like
that and then you come to columbus
that's the point and that's what to
piggyback off what mr kern said
it's a first world problem most woke
people live in the first world yeah like
their hardest thing in the morning is if
they're out of their almond milk yeah
you know and then all they have to do is
get on their phone and order it and it
will come to their door in about 15
minutes but during that 15 minutes
they're gonna get on instagram and write
some scathing emails and try to shut
down almond milk i've done that not
having enough substance in the cartons
there should be more it should be bigger
so that's the world they live in
unfortunately it's a small group yeah
i'm sure this group that wanted to get
rid of the cops wasn't five
thousand strong it was six or seven and
they're the ones who don't go to class
and those same ones that you interview
on watters world you ask them a math
question and they answer with alphabet
soup so we really
but we give them
this we're talking about it but that's
not the real pulse of this country yeah
you know and the reason why the police
are there because i guarantee you as
soon as the cops aren't there for one of
these special first worlders
they're gonna be so upset and screaming
why me where was you're supposed to
protect me where were you you know and
then they have to go to psychiatrists
and everything else because they're
abandoned by the police and somebody
will say well weren't you the guy who
said you didn't want him there well that
was different yeah so you know let him
talk but just hit mute
jesse i would like a cop-free week in
these places and then and then promote
it say like there's gonna be no cops
here for the whole week everybody i
don't think that would go well greg no i
don't think so either would go well um
and when i was in college the phrase
body count yeah has a different meaning
yeah that's true um
[Music]
you're talking about zero you're talking
about the band
um
we should apologize to the italians
i mean imagine if an american college
student had gone to italy to go to
college and had just gotten killed like
that
this would have been on fox 24 7. and we
would have been demanding let's do
something about those italians yeah and
we wouldn't want justice
but this happens in the united states in
america an ivy league institution a an
exchange student immediately gets
slaughtered
and no one says anything yeah and we
don't apologize the italians don't say
anything i mean have the italians said
anything i don't know i don't really
watch the news
[Laughter]
i am sorry to the italians
no but it's true it's it's another story
that just went away much like the you
know the uh the waukesha yeah the suv
that caused that uh that death yeah yeah
very true all right cat care to comment
on this story yeah not not to reach out
to the italians
it's called diplomacy yeah maybe
carmilla could do it yeah yeah yeah find
the root cause
uh yeah i mean i guess these they're
just more scared of being called racist
than they are of being stabbed and like
i get it you don't always want cops
around you know i don't want cops
outside my apartment all day long but if
people kept getting stabbed and shot
there i might be like you know what
there can be cops
and i think most people feel that way i
think a lot more people agree with that
but they're just afraid to say so yeah
but it's true it's like it's the
administration that just wants to appear
woke and they're they're willingly
they're willing to sacrifice student
safety to reach that end
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else